pour du cash exotiques de healy promet
leurs nerfs une carabine ou la nostalgie
c'est comme l'opium c'est un taxi parce
qu'ils me plaire et chemise blanche dans
le sous-sol du mikado
j'en ai passé des beaux dimanches je
déballe une sonnette à l'avalanche et
vous offre comme un cadeau
odeur du sein et de l'art en enjeu pour
qu'on leur fasse non c'est le kangoo
sortie d'un refrain de traîner un vieil
âne gris se traînait voyant le dos ou
une âme et une année de pas mal d'années
ce jour là dans la rue lepic ivre un peu
fort sur des pratiques
il lui mais l'odeur des légumes le
parfum subtil des agrumes et parvint au
bout d'un moment là où est la rue des
abbesses dropt il croyait tout bêtement
que c'était la rue des années la fête
des ânesses passé et le vieil homme
rêvassait jeunesse attire entre jeunesse
ah si j'avais un droit d'aînesse je le
vendrais comme les a eus
non point pour un plat de lentilles mais
pour le bon temps où j'ai eu le jarret
souple et laïcs y brille à je préfére au
pic atteint le short hon qui piquent et
le teint k2 l'ombre août à la campagne
qui veut mais qui m'accompagne les
ânesses comme il se doit
n'entendait pas ses rêveries et sur
leurs sabots suédois saut à terre vers
d'autres prêts
sur la garonne en plein bordeaux quand
les marins les matelots montech avec le
mascaret il a courait au queen mary
il s'agissait pas du bateau mais d'un
bordel au bord de l'eau qui portait ce
nom que vénérait tous les engrais le
queen mary bordeaux depuis a bien changé
plus la peine de se déranger et c'est en
vain qu'on chercherait où pourrait être
le crime mais ray mais ont quatre points
de la rose des vents il reste bien
quelques vivant parmi tous ceux qui
venaient se brise bahia et hop une
mairie c'est un temps vous savez où
depuis le
il a coulé beaucoup d'eau
sous les paons il ya eu beaucoup de
marées d'équinoxe buste en 20 mai
je peux vous raconter que le port de
bordeaux le port lui-même et
est accessible on pouvait se promener
librement sur les quais ce que je
demande le préfère d'ailleurs alors
vraiment se faisait rêver parce qu'on va
y arriver
commencée et fruits exotiques et
l'arachide
les régimes de bananes dix ans à ces
tensions bloqué en fait osciller les
bois précieux les mêmes étaient
déchargés alors se faisait attraper
parce que c'était dangereux d enfance
quand même votre temps mais pour moi
évidemment les na'vi à 30 il arrivait
quand ils repartaient ou quand il était
à l'ancré en plus de leur cargaison de
fruits ou de bois avec leur cargaison
aussi de beaux rêves en angleterre ou
bien ailleurs
il ya bien sûr terre des bornes en
vigueur qui s'en souviennent en secret
si on revivait le temps de la guerre
c'est pas la guerre fut giret et de bon
coeur je crois que murray m'offrir un
verre aux prunes mairie
a71 ai-je connu la misère ou simplement
la pauvreté je ne sais plus je ne sais
pas je ne me suis jamais aperçu de rien
j'étais tellement habillé d'amour
cajoler versés par ma mère nous vivions
mes parents et moins dans un immense et
frôlant hôtel particulier dans la porte
cochère ans condamnée depuis longtemps
s'ouvrait une autre porte tout petit
prévu pour les petites gens l'adresse de
mes parents n'en était pas moins place
de la monnaie
enfin on n'avait plus le rose et de
primes et de chapeau à qui la faute à
qui la cause
s'il n'est plus de fleurs et d'oiseaux
les roses sont artificielles oiseaux qui
passent on le fera également et sur les
statuts les officiels les pigeons noir
seul pour le québec
mon fils est dans la fleur de l'âge et
moi qui mets du temps jadis
je m'en vais on était au chômage ou
s'inscrire à bientôt mon fils aux
jeunesses requise des larmes devant le
mur de l'avenir car sinon pays vend des
armes ce n'est pas pour t'entretenir
l'existence ce qu'on nous fait vivre
nasillo heureux des transistors corps du
dollar et de la libre du coach marc est
bilingue audard un ministre prend la
parole notre avenir dépend dit-il de
l'indispensable pétrole et du prix
d'achat du baril
voilà déjà annulé
et vous verrez
tout va changer ne craignez rien et
c'est vous faire ou vous dit que ce sans
danger mais d'autres disent le contraire
monsieur rostand je suis bon bar
oui ce sont des retardataires
des gens à part
sur les flammes c'est sur l'allemagne
passons
contre les
pour les large de cap de la hague
on y met
on tenait
alors j'aurais loupé s'éloigne
voyez sur l'océan toutes les îles et le
de bras par signé deux belles jusqu'à
ouessant
les pros argent on lise en place
s'explique les promoteurs les mètres
carrés
en surface se sont rentables en hauteur
c'est ainsi que les membres eux mêmes
et encore
pour leurs cimetières hlm c'est un bon
humble mais c'est vrai
il avait vu d'en haut
le choix qu à qui la faute
qui n'est plus joueur et 300
il y avait dans une courte rue
perpendiculaire au cours de l'intendance
lieu de promenade de rendez-vous de
rencontre des étudiants et des
étudiantes
lorsque le 6 heures du soir avait
gravement sonné à la cathédrale
saint-andré il y avait 10 rue franklin
un lieu qui m'attirait qui me fascinait
c'était le trianon théâtre c'était un
très joli théâtre à l'italienne c'est
aujourd'hui un cinéma spécialisé
peut-être dans les films de catégorie x
je ne sais pas nous verrons bien
toujours est il qu'à mes saisons on lit
jouait une pièce par semaine je ne
manque pas une
le directeur du théâtre d'alors était
monsieur kléber arpin qui était aussi
mon professeur de comédie au
conservatoire de bordeaux
mes parents n'ayant pas fait obstacle
aux choix de ma profession
ce qui devait arriver arriva je suis
engagé à l'année par monsieur arpin
chers fantômes de comédien au nom eva
peut-il encore une silhouette une voix
familière
j'ai eu le plaisir de jouer au près
nouveau gens marchent à chaque beau mère
marguerite moreno marcel genia henry
bosque l'unip
bordeaux je le ressentais justement
instinctivement comme un enfant et en
regardant pour les la garonne je le
voyais cette carotte chargé de terre sur
la couleur de des terres que mes cousins
cultivateurs continuent de
cultivée elle était l'été les marrons et
il faut bien dire des chars is cet égard
il est riche
je me sentais justement à bordeaux sur
ce pont je me sentais à la fois venant
du haut
je ne sentais rien et en regardant vers
le large il sentait marins dès la levée
de visage une famille de costumes les
vieux marin pêcheur quand il fait soleil
sur le quai tête doucettement leur pipe
qu'ils allument à la flamme géante est
ridicule d'un briquet c'est mieux que
l'ama doute et le briquet tempête un lot
gagné jadis à la tombola du moindre
cadeau du neveu qui sur le lafayette la
serbie matelots il a rapporté ici
second venu de le suivre et qui sait
donner tant de peine
à contre courant sur à c'est dans ce
premier jour de printemps
le tu as dit le vent au passage
bien entendu pont mirabeau
je n'en sais rien et qu'il faisait beau
jeu des patrons
et son message m
depuis le temps je suis né
mon entendement dit mindi je vois que la
nuit est venue
et je crois que l'heure a sonné
voici déjà la nuit des prix et saute
promet que je dois bras
ve
j'ai souvent charroi de nuages tombe de
toutes les terres du prix
c'est clair où le monde puis
aussi elle va s'entrouvrir
le temps continue de courir les genoux
pas de vive je voudrais mourir et poney
mais gilles pleuvent sur ma tête nue
je vois que louvain prévenu et j'entends
l'aise au sony
et
tous ces fronts et grimaçant
le bac la banque
dont la villa des fous du monde reçu la
note il me passant
je dis ça je lai bassin
pour salle magnan la d'oise
et moi non
regarde vraiment choix
dans le sang
mais je mets mes schraner
ben l'hiver balaye la venue
je sais que la nuit est venue
dites moi qu'est le saunier
on